oh you guys take cam way too seriously
calling all the demigods whether you
belong to camp halfblood or camp jupiter
we've all been obsessed with the percy
jackson series at one point in time
fans of the books probably already know
how much the two movies changed but
today we're taking a look at specific
moments the films got wrong
and just why some fans think the new
disney plus series could be the do-over
they've been waiting for
she would squash you like a bug her name
annabeth chase daughter of athena and
the demigod that managed to steal not
only percy jackson's heart but our
hearts as well
there's no doubt that the movie
portrayed her as absolutely
stunning with her dark straight hair and
piercing blue eyes but that anabath was
a far cry from the description rick
riordan wrote in his novels
book annabeth had curly blonde hair and
gray eyes
so basically the opposite of what we saw
on screen
they did try and lighten her hair a bit
in the sea of monsters film
but they just couldn't hit the mark and
if that wasn't enough the movie got
annabeth's age all wrong
in the film annabeth and percy are 16
years old but in the books
they were only 12 they weren't even
supposed to be teenagers
hey no staring speaking of annabeth and
percy
their relationship in the movies
compared to the books was drastically
different because
of that major age change in the first
book the two 12 year olds didn't exactly
get off to a great start but they
eventually learned how to work together
and become friends
now moving over to the lightning thief
film well let's just say things got
heated fast and we're not talking about
the two demigods clashing heads
by the end of the films we had plenty of
romantic scenes to prove that perka bath
was
definitely a thing of course we know
that at the end of the percy jackson
book series
perka bath is end game but the movies
and their age
definitely sped up that process
i think i am the son of poseidon before
percy's relationship with anabeth could
even start he of course had to be
introduced to camp half-blood
and to the casual fact that he was a
demi-god
no big deal in the movie after fighting
the minotaur
percy wakes up three days later and
realizes that his father is poseidon
god of the sea yep you're a demigod
but it takes a little longer for percy
to find out his paternity in the books
he's only claimed by poseidon after
defeating the heiress campers
speaking of his powers that's also
something that's drastically different
in the movies and books
in the movies percy starts to master his
powers almost immediately but in the
novel series it takes multiple books for
him to even get to the point we see him
at in the movies
we don't exactly know why they made this
change but it could have been to make
the movies a little more engaging
that's because all gods are the same
they only care about themselves
before percy figures out that maybe luke
castellan
isn't the greatest company to have
around luke gives him an epic pair of
shoes
shoes that literally have wings and
allow the person wearing them to fly
in the movies percy puts the shoes to
good use he uses them to collect the
pearl in parthenon
and even in his final battle with luke
for the bolt
but in the books we don't ever really
get to read about them in action
percy is actually scared to use them
because of zeus's threat against him
occupying his sky and gives the shoes to
grover
well in the book it turns out he was
right not to use them he would have
literally been dragged down to tartarus
oh there it is
lotus casino underage demigods walk into
a casino
what could go wrong a lot in the
lightning thief
when percy annabeth and grover visit the
lotus casino in the films
their adventure to stop the godly war is
put on pause and that's because of some
delicious
addictive lotus treats that lure them
into staying there for a whole five days
that's really good
the same thing pretty much happens in
the book except instead of lotus treats
they were given green credit cards that
completely took away their concept of
time
while we're not exactly happy they
changed things from the book we have to
admit
those lotus snacks did look kinda tasty
welcome to the underworld eventually
percy does make it to the underworld in
the lightning thief
and in the films is greeted by
persephone also known as haiti's wife
but she is literally being kept captive
in his quarters
the book on the other hand is much tamer
persephone doesn't even make an
appearance because she's away spending
the summer with her mother
you're hermes little insulted you didn't
recognize me moving on to the
differences in sea of monsters
let's start small kinda and talk about
the gifts hermes gives percy to help him
on his quest
the god chooses a calming beach in the
books to give percy the powerful thermos
the movie took this moment and made it
extra
percy annabeth and tyson meet hermes at
the olympic postal service that's
disguised as a ups store
maybe the beach was just too tame for
the producer the scriptwriters
really woke up that day and chose glam
imagine annabeth passing we'd never
forgive rick or any movie producer who
would make that a reality
oh wait it kind of did become reality
only in the sea monsters movie that is
while fighting the manticore she was
fatally hurt and fans cried along with
percy when it happened
luckily she was brought back to life by
the fleece in the books
annabeth was only badly injured and it
was from polyphemus during battle
the fleece also came to the rescue in
this situation and healed her
kronos is one of the most important
villains in the percy jackson series
and is the reason a lot of the events in
the series occur however
cronus doesn't claim a host and rise
until the book
the battle of the labyrinth but in the
sea of monsters movie kronos not only
rises but rises without finding a host
could this have been because the
filmmakers already knew they weren't
going to be able to bring the rest of
the book series to life
what do you think i heard there was a
prophecy about me
why is it that all heroes have a
prophecy to fulfill
harry potter ray skywalker they're
always tasked with these big shoes they
have to fill
just like percy jackson but the way
percy finds out about the prophecy
changes whether you're watching the
movies or
reading the books in the book the last
olympian percy receives the prophecy by
reading a handwritten note that had been
in the necklace around the oracle's neck
it's supposed to come true when he turns
16. however in the films percy is told
the prophecy by the oracle of delphi
in the sea of monsters film to top it
all off the prophecy is meant to come to
be
when he is 20.
imagine this you read about harry
potter's invisibility cloak in the books
and then find out the cloak does not
exist in the movies
the concept seems laughable right well
that's what happened to annabeth in the
film adaptations
in the sea of monsters book annabeth
uses her knife and cap of invisibility
to save the gang multiple times
the knife is even more special because
it's the cursed knife of the prophecy
but in the movies both of her weapons
don't really make an appearance
instead percy's sword and a klusmos
is the cursed sword of the prophecy and
uh
a extra shot of nectar this last one
isn't as big as excluding annabeth's
weapons but it's still a difference we
had to mention
in the books nectar is a demigod
medicine that could cause combustion
if you took a little too much but in the
movie specifically sea of monsters
we're told nectar is just a casual drink
that you can get at a demigod cafe
i've lived now that we've gone over just
how much the 2010
and 2013 films got wrong let's go over
what we know about the newest percy
jackson series that was just announced
and how disney plus might just be the
ones to finally get it right
we haven't gotten any confirmation on
the cast but we do know that rick is
heavily involved
this means that everything rick had
issues with in the original adaptations
like the ages of the characters
will probably be fixed although it'll be
hard to say goodbye to logan lerman as
our percy
maybe we'll finally get the screen
series we've all been waiting for
we can all agree that the film and book
series are drastically different
from major plot points all the way to
the color of annabeth's hair
but we have our fingers crossed for
percy jackson fans everywhere
hopefully disney plus can put their
godlike powers forward and finally give
us the adaptation we deserve
[Applause]
[Music]
what are your thoughts on the changes
the movies made did you enjoy them
tell us all your percy jackson thoughts
below thanks for watching the things
[Music]
fans